jams in California hey Jan how are you
hope I'm ready to talk with you today
you too what's up I had a question about
whether you think I can self-insure
long-term care so I've been listening to
you for about the past year and has made
some changes in my retirement I will
tell you that my husband and I have
already purchased a long-term care
policy I'm 55 so I know I went too early
my husband is 60 and our premiums are
due next month and I'm thinking about
maybe canceling mine okay well the
chances
statistically of using a long-term care
insurance policy before age 60 are
substantially less than one-half of one
percent and that's why we recommend
sixty and beyond on the purchase of it
it just doesn't happen in other words
and so then as far as self-insuring
through long-term care that would just
have to be with your wealth and how much
of it you'd be willing to burn in and
how much you can burn and still be safe
in nursing home care and so what is your
what is your net worth or your nest egg
size okay about four million dollars
okay so I have an over name in my 401k
my husband has 250 in a Roth IRA we had
about 400 thousand in just investments
we were sort out a pension and he can't
get his until he's 65 okay here's the
here's an error number the average the
average household that uses long term
care which is most people by the way end
up with some level of in-home care or
nursing home care one of the two it
lasts two point four years on average
less than 1/4 go longer than that so you
have a one in four chance of going
longer than two point four years the
number of people that use it
years or more is almost zero because
usually once you need the care your
health is in decline is what it amounts
to and so that that's what it comes to
so if and then you know the national
average is 50 to 75 thousand a year for
a nursing home care you're in California
might be higher than that where you are
you'd have to look and see but let's
just play with some numbers let's take
the high side a hundred thousand the
average is two point four hardly anybody
goes five years but if you went five
years there'd be five hundred thousand
out of your four million your husband
would still be okay okay and so your
self insuring for five hundred thousand
dollar event with a four million dollar
istic or four million dollar net worth
and in Reverse for him to but if each of
you if each of you exceeded the averages
by double and you went through a million
of the four million your estate is still
three million dollars well so yeah
you're in a position to self-insure as
long as you're willing to play those
odds right okay does that do you see the
math I'm doing well I I totally do like
not just whispering that yelling in my
other ear that I need long-term care
insurance which is why I got it well you
do if you don't have a fort if you don't
have a four million dollar net worth you
do because what happens let's think
let's take a typical family has a
$500,000 nest egg which is a pretty good
nest egg for most people right the 75%
of the ladies outlive their husbands and
so the normal scenario with that family
is Papa goes into the nursing home burns
through 300 grand leaves mama 200 grand
when he dies and that's not that's not a
scenario you want to do that's leaving
everybody to cheaped out right so we do
need long-term care insurance for those
people which is most people I mean
there's only 11 million millionaires in
America and so you know that's you and
me and a few others you know and so that
that's it
and so everybody until you get to that
level that you can afford to take that
three to five hundred
dollar hit and the person left behind is
still in excellent financial shape then
you would definitely want long-term care
insurance so the voice yelling in your
ear is a great one it's a it's a big
deal it's a big big problem so thanks
for your call see what we've got is
we've got the boomers have what we call
them the Sandwich Generation now because
their parents are needing this 50 to
$100,000 care their kids are going into
college at fifty to a hundred thousand a
year and they're getting hit from both
sides both these groups wanting help
from them if you got your Mama and Daddy
in a nursing home and your kid in
college yeah yeah yeah it's bad it gets
bad fast and so you would need long-term
care insurance or have built a great net
worth like you guys have done
congratulations by the way very well
done